what's up guys today we're gonna be
taking a look at the samsung 960 evil
nvme SSD and 250 gigabyte so guys in the
box there's this little tiny tab on the
top
it's tiny black tab
once you get that tab open the whole top
the top comes off and there's a little
tab right here they can use it from here
to pull out or just slightly easier
actually now here's the m2 there's a
little plastic cover on top of this just
comes straight off and reveals the end
of to and there's little tap I hope you
guys enjoyed that quick unboxing and if
you guys liked that and want to see more
details about put em down - are you sure
to check out my review which would be
linked in the description below if you
guys liked that video make sure to give
me a like if you guys loved it and would
like to see more videos just like that
make sure to subscribe and until next
time bye